In Ukraine, President Petro Poroshenko proposes martial law throughout the country...
...for 30 days starting Wednesday,...
...after Russia fired on and seized three Ukrainian naval vessels Sunday...
...off the coast of Russian-annexed Crimea.
Russia says the vessels illegally entered its territory.
The United States warns Russia that "outlaw actions"...
...like the seizure of Ukrainian ships in the Sea of Azov...
...are preventing normal relations from developing between Washington and Moscow.
In Somalia, Al-Shabab militants killed at least 22 people Monday...
...in a raid on the compound of a controversial cleric...
...in the central Somali town of Galkayo.
In the US, President Donald Trump says Mexico should send migrants...
...seeking asylum in the United States back to their home countries,...
...a day after US authorities shut the country's busiest southern border crossing...
...and fired tear gas into the crowd.
Finally from the US, General Motors says...
...it will slash 15 percent of its salaried workforce...
...and halt production at five facilities across North America,...
...a move it says is motivated by market pressure.